foot baths are all the rage right now on social media. Would you suggest that as a detox potential?
No. So there's with the true rife package people got, most people got, and I had a pro wave.
That's what true rife called it, from true rife. And they really, when Mike
Tigley are came out with that. He really pushed it as a detox tool. And, and it's really detoxied.
And it's really, really good for you using the ion foot baths.
So understand, true iotic foot baths are using ions by positively charging the water,
and then negatively charging the water. And the good ionic foot baths you can set to how you
could run an all positive charge. You could run it all negative charge. So an ion is a positive
or a negative charge. So you could run it 70% positive 30% negative vice versa. Whatever you
want to do as, you know, as the practitioner using it or whoever's administrating the ionic
foot baths. Well, you know, since those first came out about 15 years ago, there's been a lot
of other cheap delcops of the market that you just put in the water. You just turn them on. You
have no idea what it's, if it's really ionizing the water. If it is at what a positive charge or
negative charge, the idea was if you're running a positive charge, you could be pulling out negatively
charged ions. So you could be pulling stuff out of the tissues. Does that help you detoxify?
Yes, it does. Is it worth doing it? Well, people really like it because the water changes colors
and it's exciting because oh my gosh, look at all that junk. I just must have pulled out of my body.
Now, I do believe it works. We have used the ion foot bath. Not that I unproy from Turek. So don't
don't mix this up. So we have used a, I forgot the brand that we used to use in the office.
There's two brands, Erkodia and then this ion pro, there's which the one we use, I can't
remember the one we use. So there's two professional models that were out there that I think were
equally good. So we used what we used in the office. That was a true ionic foot bath.
And we did people with chemotherapy and the water would actually become like
phosphorus. I mean, it was literally like, there's lots of chemicals in that water.
And it wasn't like that before they did chemotherapy. So I'm convinced that you were pulling out
things. But those companies used to distribute like color or paraplets like if it's this color,
you're pulling this out. If it's this color, you're pulling this out of this color.
Quite honestly, I just don't, I've stated this dozens of times when people have asked this question,
I don't adhere to the belief of that because I've done it enough with people that that's just
isn't true. And you couldn't literally put one of those things just in the water with nobody's
speed in it. And you're going to get some discoloration of that water because you're iodizing it.
So there is minerals in that water that you are iodizing it. It's going to cause a discoloration
of that water. So is it really a great tool for detoxification? I think it could be helpful,
but I'm not sure it's a great tool. Now, again, I said, don't confuse this with the iron pro
wave from true right because the iron pro wave from true right is just a way to get higher frequencies
in your body. And there will be some detoxification when you do that. But that's a totally different
philosophy. It's not iodizing the water. You're running specific frequencies through the water.
You're not iodizing the water at a positive or negative iron. There can be benefits to both. So
but is it something you should run out by an iron pro wave or a foot bath? I would say no.
If you have access to it, if you want to do it and it makes you feel a lot better doing it,
then I think that's fine. Do it it. But I don't think it's necessary. Nor do I think it makes a
giant difference in your detoxification. If you're much better off if you're going to spend money
on something like that to buy a sauna, that's going to be a much better use of finances.
Get out one of those nip-up salads or something like that. And it would be to get a
iodine. Put that.